et on débute ce journal avec ce procès
qui s'est ouvert aujourd'hui au tribunal
correctionnel de tours
neuf hommes sont jugés pour avoir blessé
par balle un individu à la sortie du
pimms boîte de nuit deux tours
des faits qui remontent à septembre 2010
est une dizaine de douilles avaient été
retrouvées sur place
témoin d'une véritable expédition
punitive effet avec lucas schouppe à
l'issue de la sphère aurait pu être
dramatique tout part d'une dispute d'une
altercation sur fond d'alcool au pimps
le 3 septembre 2010 est une partie des
protagonistes vient du sanitas et
l'autre du quartier rival de la rabière
à joué les tours
quelques coups de téléphone plus tard et
des voitures descente de jouer vers
tours et donne l'assaut sur une voiture
dans laquelle se trouvent les jeunes du
sanitas bilan un blessé grave touché par
un tir d'armes de guerre aujourd'hui cet
homme s'est constituée partie civile
mais est détenu en attendant d'être jugé
dans une autre affaire de règlement de
comptes
pourtant pour son avocat cela ne doit
pas altérer son statut de victime
un laborieux un énorme préjudice pour
rappel c'est comme une victime de tirs
par arme à feu il ya une hospitalisation
et de graves séquelles qui ne sont
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui pas forcément
consolidé donc c'est important de le
comprendre et ne pas encore une fois
occulter cette qualité parce que il sera
dans quelques semaines dans le box des
prévenus
autre particularité de la sphère les
multiples requalification un temps
pressenti pour comparaître aux assises
pour tentative de meurtre puis
d'assassinât les neuf prévenus se
retrouve finalement face au tribunal
correctionnel pour association de
malfaiteurs en vue de commettre un crime
mais nouveau rebondissement ce matin le
procureur a annoncé que ses réquisitions
porterait sur une association de
malfaiteurs en vue de commettre un délit
et non plus un crime
les prévenus eux pour beaucoup
reconnaissent leur présence dans la nuit
à joué les tours mais tous nient leur
implication dans la fusillade
mon client - il est présent 1 il est vu
sur les caméras de vidéosurveillance à
joué-lès-tours reste à démontrer par
monsieur le procureur de la république
qui étaient effectivement présents sur
les lieux de la fusillade
ce qui est pas du tout certain quand
bien même ils auraient été présents sur
les lieux ce qui était conscient que
c'était en vue de la préparation d'un
crime ou d'un délit
le jugement est attendu vendredi soir
les neuf prévenus encourent dix ans
d'emprisonnement ferme